If you are a fan of the Japanese martial art of Aikido,
you just came to the right place!
Welcome to YouTube's best Aikido channel!
We conduct exclusive interviews
with the most prestigious masters in Japan and beyond,
we take you behind the scenes
of the major events in the Aikido World.
We offer you a front seat
to the most exciting demonstrations,
and,
We uncover the roots of Aikido
through the secret ancient art of Daito-ryu Aiki-jujutsu.
Join us and meet our vibrant community
to see what you can learn.
Subscribe now to get notified with every new video
and support our work on Patreon
so we can keep bringing you the
best of Aikido from Japan.